so ah that brings us to this last topic
of PI data burning 2017 and it's
Jonathan Ronan he's PhD fellow at max
delbruck Center and he's going to talk
about social networks and protest
participation so give him a big big
round of applause please
[Applause]
hi
thank you both for staying for the last
talk I'm sure they're you know in this
lovely Sunday afternoon my name is
Jonathan Ronan I briefly introduced
myself I am an electrical engineer by
training then I worked three years as a
software engineer around Europe then I
went to work as a data scientist in a
computational social science lab at New
York University that's where this work
I'm going to present right now it's from
and currently and pursuing my PhD in
computational biology here in Berlin so
I'm going to talk to you about this very
famous protest that happened on a
January 11 2015 when hundreds of
thousands of Parisians marched in the
streets of Paris in a March culminating
here at the plasterer republic in
solidarity with the victims of an attack
at the headquarters of the Charlie Hebdo
magazine
now this March wasn't a surprising event
in any sense we all knew this was going
to happen it was planned and announced
in advance but if I maybe a little toast
Olien about this toast Orion about this
sorry each one of these people made the
decision to protest each one of them
individually chose to go to protest and
the reasons that motivate people to
participate in events like these have
kept social scientists busy for many
decades I it conventionally believed
that the decision to protest is a social
one but until recently with all of the
advances that you heard about in the
last talk it's been difficult for social
scientists to tackle these questions in
a context of a network structure with
empirical data and not just game
theoretic models researchers before have
a direct right to address these
questions using post-processed surveys
where they ask participants
after the fact why they participated up
and gern interviewed participants in the
in the marches in Leipzig in 1989 were
the demanded reforms from the GDR
government in protests that are largely
seen as the the beginning of the
downfall of that oppressive regime and
they were they showed that the social
ties of these participants were crucial
in motivating them to come out and
protest in this under this repressive
regime where it was believed that people
fear at participating protests because
of the regime macadam impulse and
interviewed people who participated in
the Chicago Freedom Summer in 1963 which
was an effort to register as many black
and minority voters and they also showed
that it wasn't just the social size but
the salience of those social ties and
the different spheres in which they they
occur that motivate people to
participate both of these studies and
others have a number of shortcomings
first of all their retrospective up and
groin interview people one year after
the demonstration was macadam and toss
in a couple of decades after the after
the activist activities they typically
interview a small number of people and
they don't really have a network
structure and that they asked people did
you know any other people who
participated but they don't know who
your friends know and so it's not really
a network structure today when people
protest they often post messages on
social media announcing that they will
protest in addition to planning these in
advance and I'm sure that you can
understand the big opportunities that
this big data will enable us as social
scientists to research this using big
empirical data we're not the first to
notice this of course here's a couple of
really interesting Twitter networks
papers first
Pablo Barbera I showed that using the
Twitter network you can actually
estimate two very high accuracy people's
political leaning and a left-to-right
access Alexandre Segal showed that a
network structure of people
participating in in the sunni-shia a a
Glee slur debates on Twitter sort of
participate
sort of show that people using the worst
anti sectarian slurs are actually
embedded in more diverse networks and
this is actually a cross sectarian
conversation going on on social media
rather than just a flame war so there's
countless other studies of course and if
we want to use this network to study
protest participation here's the sort of
data set that we wish we could obtain
right so first of all we would like a
set of confirmed protesters who went to
the event we like all of their social
ties and all of the ties of their ties
so that we can actually see the network
structure that they're embedded in and
not just their immediate friends who are
also participants or not participant and
finally we would like a set of control
set users so that we may compare the
network structures of the protesters to
some sensible other set of potential
protesters the chose not to protest so
we went ahead and collected this data
set first of all before the protest on
the day of the attack we set up a
twitter twitter stream collection
tracking a number of the most popular
hashtags and keywords that people used
while discussing these events on twitter
this was a fairly standard practice in
the lab whenever something happened in
the world it was a might carry political
participation from social media in the
world we would start collecting all of
these tweets from all of these Charlie
Hebdo je suis charlie tweets we were
able to identify a set of 764 users who
tweeted from the plasterer public during
the last two hours of the March so we're
confident they were actually protestors
and we also identified a set of a
thousand control users who while we're
not sure they weren't at the March at
some point we're sure they weren't at
the March on one particular point
because they tweeted using geocoding
from a distance away from the March at
the time that it was going on and we
like I said we're not sure they didn't
actually go to the to the protest but I
would I would say say that any
contamination we have of actual
protesters into our control group would
only make any claims we make later
stronger
finally we build out a network from
their friends and their friends friends
on Twitter getting a big network
structure and just go through this
visually again first we collect all the
tweets mentioning any of these hashtags
we draw a box around the + la république
or we can filter out some users who
tweet with geocoding from there or from
a minimum distance away from there we
call those the participants in the
controls then for each of these we use
the Twitter REST API to get all of the
list of people they follow and build out
the network and finally we pass that on
to downstream analysis tools so when we
do this for controls and our a and our
protesters to two degrees out Twitter is
actually a very small world network we
get 120 million nodes this is actually
not a hundred and twenty million nodes I
had difficulties visualizing such a big
network so this is just a subsample of
them if you can see the colors on the
screen some of these dots are green some
of them are red those are protestors and
controls and the grey dots are just
their friends when you lay them out and
using a force-directed layout algorithm
like this you sort of see there's a
community network emerging where some
people are followed by a few protesters
found very few controls you can't really
use this to tell apart the participants
from the non participant this isn't
really the way to go forward so in order
to use this network to say something
about how does the network motivate
people to participate or not we came up
with this network theory of protest we
continue in the in the tradition of
social science and game theory saying
that people choose to protest if the
value of the protest is high enough for
them and further that as my exposure to
other people who value the protest
highly increases my own valuation of the
protest is going to increase and then in
the context of Twitter we say this well
exposure is going to be a function of
network distance as well as high
strength
so let me show you what we mean by that
we imagine Twitter at this big graph of
follower relationships that it whereby
we can sort of approximate the exposure
of users to other users so for instance
if a follows B or a has a tie to B then
we say a is exposed to be further if B
follows C then even if a does not follow
C a is exposed to C albeit to a lesser
degree than its exposure to B because we
might retweet some of the things C says
people might also have reciprocated tags
on twitter where they follow each other
this indicates a stronger relationship
more likely to be an offline
relationship so we say this tie is
stronger and therefore the exposure to
each other more meaningful and finally
we the Triad a centered around a user a
with a follows two users B and C and at
least one of them follows each other we
again know that these relationships are
more likely to be offline relationships
or have more context to them and we say
that a is exposure to both B and C is
more meaningful than had C not followed
B in that example so using using those
definitions let me walk you through some
of the hypotheses we have about how the
protesters Twitter network might differ
from that of control sets so all the
blue ones on the right here would
signify protesters or just our controls
the red ones in the middle are people
they follow white ones outside there are
people who their friends follow but they
don't actually follow themselves so
let's use this this little toy example
here to show you what I mean using the
definitions I just went through
so our first hypothesis is that
protesters will have more tie to other
protesters then a random control group
will have among themselves so if you
look at all of the bold ties over there
and all of the not so bold ties over
there these are all ties that go from
protesters to other people and we expect
that the proportion of ties to remain
within the group will be higher for
protesters than for controls
second we expect protesters to have more
ties of ties to protesters so all of the
arrows that aren't dashed here are ties
that go out from the middle layer of
protesters friends and we expect that
for protesters more of these will go
back to protesters than for the control
group thirdly if we look at triads
centered at protesters if you look at
the top most triad they're centered at
protester with two non protester friends
there at the bottom most high a triad
Center another protester has another
protester has a triad member and we
hypothesize that protesters will have
more triads where at least one other
member of the triad is a protestor then
control groups would have among
themselves and finally we posit that
protesters will have more strong ties to
each other then control group members
would have to each other so using the
all the data we collected before we're
able to compute these statistics for all
the protesters and see if we're actually
right about this is to the protesters
have a meaningfully different network
structure than our control set so first
of all ties with in-group you can see we
counted for each protestor is what
proportion of their ties goes to other
protesters for each control group member
what proportion of their ties goes back
to another control group member again
you see this much higher spike at 0% for
controls than for protesters this is a
log normal distribution seems like an a
highly significant difference between
them the same goes for tides of ties
with a much again a log normal
distribution with protesters having
significantly more ties of ties to
protesters then control group users have
two other control group members a triads
that include another protester again see
this very sad tale for protesters in a
very sharp decline for controls showing
that again protesters have significantly
more triads that include another
protesters
and controls do with another control and
finally also with a strong ties we again
see this log normal distribution with
significant difference significantly
more strong ties between protesters than
between control group members so all of
these tests we've done here are also a
robust to our choice of control set we
thought you know maybe our is just
something funny about our Paris control
that we chose we gathered another
control set of users who rather than
being Parisians are just French and geo
tweet from friends at some point we show
that this set is actually
indistinguishable from the parrot from
the Paris control set in all of these
tests that we have they have the same
ties with in-group triads in strong ties
etc further there's something on Twitter
calls verified accounts these are
typically different network hubs like
newspapers politicians famous people we
thought these might bias biases in some
way if if Barack Obama or Justin Bieber
follows one of the protesters this might
just seem like a dense denser network so
we remove all the verified accounts and
again we recapitulate all the results
then we ask ourselves well what if these
people that well tweeted from Placido
public are just a bunch of friends who
go places and tweet together from there
and they're not protestors at all to
answer that we just put up a box around
the plaza a public to see how often do
people actually tweet from there that
might not be protesters in over a period
of two weeks when we try that nobody
tweeted from there so it's not like a
twitter twitter user party gathering
place also we asked ourselves well what
if these people just don't care about
Charlie Hebdo or Paris users and that's
why they didn't go to the protest and
everything else is incidental but let me
remind you we collected these users from
selves users who had tweeted using some
Charlie Hebdo hashtags here is the
volume of tweets that mention Charlie
Hebdo or the associated hashtags for in
the blue line on top the protesters and
the green line in the middle
the
attenders the first spike right there is
the day of the attack and the second
spike is the day of the March and we see
that there are similar levels of
interest in this event both for the
controlled set Parisians we have as well
as the protesters so these are really
users people who live in Paris knew
about this cared about this tweeted
about this
by all accounts could have gone to the
protest chose not to so this is a very
meaningful control group to control to
compare to next one reviewer asked us
well how do you know these people didn't
just meet at the protest and form all of
these ties afterwards we did in fact
only gather all of these in network ties
after the after the protest had taken
place so using the Twitter API you can
know when someone started following
another user but when you get their
lists of followers its chronologically
ordered so you know who the first user
they started following is in through the
last lines so figure out if that's the
case then the protestor protester tides
would skew more towards the end of the
list this is not the case the normal
distribution both for protesters ties to
non protesters as well as protesters
ties among themselves some of you might
be French speakers and noticed that the
list of hashtags that are used earlier
to pick these users actually included
some some very negative hashtags such as
I am NOT Charlie or even I am Kawachi
where he was one of the shooters and
then we asked ourselves why did we even
keep those in there maybe we just got a
set of people who tweeted about this
using the negative hashtags and that's
why they didn't show up to the protest
so all of the negative hashtags are
actually big exists in both groups
strangely enough but in very low numbers
and most of most of these keywords are
just neutral or positive to the protest
and finally something I added just in
the last minute because topic models
seems to be a hot topic in this
conference so we did it slightly
differently here rather than topic
modeling texts I topic bottled
the follower lists of people so here I
imagine that the generative process
rather than me picking topics to write
my document about and then taking a word
from that distribution I pick a topic to
follow someone on Twitter from and then
I pick someone who belongs to that topic
so rather than topics being bags of
words topics or bags of popular Twitter
accounts typically these will be like
these are the football players you know
these are the left-wing politicians
these are comedians etcetera so you know
I did this for all of the people in all
three of our universities using all of
the most followed accounts in this big
matrix here sorry each row is one of the
users and each column is one of the
significant and robust topics that
emerge when you when you do this
analysis if you can see the the color
bar on the left side there has some
green red and blue lines indicating
whether this is a protester a Paris
person non protester or a france control
group non protester and the the pattern
that emerges here is that we have some
topics that are largely interesting for
Paris people whether they protest or not
we have some topics that are largely
interesting for France people whether
they're present or not but if you see
this dendogram on the right on the left
side signify as I try to cluster people
according to the people they follow on
Twitter without much greater success
than that so we can't really tell by
whom you follow if you'll go to the
protest but we do actually observe in
this data that there is a growing sphere
of influence between the protesters the
Paris and the friends but the signal is
not clear enough to say any more than
that so in conclusion we found
compelling evidence both for the network
structure hypothesis and the Thai
strengths hypothesis which is a robust
to the different control groups and all
the other things I show you this is the
first such large-scale empirical study
showing that the structure of networks
is important in motivating people and I
hope I've
I've demonstrated that as the previous
speaker said there's a lot to be gained
from empirical data big data in social
science
further we also got all of the tweets of
these people we were wondering if
there's some way we could actually find
causality in this data is it the
structure of these networks that really
motivated them or is there something
else that causes them both to form such
networks and protest more is there any
way you could use the text of the tweets
to to find the motivation in Twitter if
the Twitter networks actually are
important at all so with that I'd like
to thank all of the tool makers some of
whom might might have been at this
conference today with the help of all of
these fantastic libraries this was a
very technically simple study to
accomplish and finally I'd like to thank
my collaborators on this work
professor Jen Larson who conceptualized
the study and wrote a paper and
professors Jonathan Nagler and Josh
Tucker at NYU politics who were with us
all through the all through the process
and everybody else at the social media
and political participation lab at NYU
and thank you for listening questions
question
pick up someone
when we're doing topic modeling on the
user's what kind of information do you
collect about the user just the user
names or their profile descriptions too
so I collect no information about them
except for who follows them and when
you're doing topic modeling in text
typically you'll have a bag of words
representation of a document so here I
have a bag of Twitter accounts through
presentation of each user all the
accounts you follow are the words and I
don't know anything else about them
except who tends to be followed together
ok so the model can be improved if you
include other information like
description of the accounts or their
tweets by others a lot there's all work
on including informative Pryor's in
these topic models and I've done none of
that great so any more questions
hi thanks for the talk have you tackled
the problem on distinguishing between
paid protests and normal protests so the
term astroturfing something I think
about so you mean if these people were
paid to go protest we haven't done
anything about this
there was one anomaly we noticed in our
data set where some of the accounts none
of the protesters but some of the
friends if we just draw a histogram of
how many people follow how many people
you follow there seems to be like a
decreasing you know thing with a big
peak around 2001 so you know we we asked
some people about this one of them said
oh yeah a lot of us have exactly 2,000
people whom they follow so all we did
was again exclude all of these from the
analysis we're getting the same results
we did we didn't really look into who
paid for these parts where they came
from
a very interesting thing to study on
Twitter of course hi my name is reka
I also studied political sciences and I
did some Twitter stuff during my studies
and one thing I've noticed during the
recent years that Twitter changes access
to its API sometimes how did that relate
to your work do you have difficulties of
that and besides my question I just
would like to point out and remark and
what I noticed in your talk is that you
concentrated a lot on building up the
actual measurement model before going to
your result in comparison to the other
talks I saw doing that and doing this
conference that really stood out for me
and maybe the question for that the
second question what do you think about
the machine learning approaches really
digging in and exploring stuff or
setting up a measurement model
I'm sorry what was the first question
again Twitter API changes right so there
I remember the changes that affected my
work the most with this were the
changing rate limits on Twitter and
without going into too much detail and
and you know sabotaging my future
working collaborators you just need to
be able to clever about working around
the Twitter API rate limit and as for
you know setting out your hypotheses in
advance versus exploratory data analysis
obviously that's what we did we got all
the data we thought of a different
million different statistics to to
compute and we we and we did that this
topic modeling you know is exactly that
kind of thing we just said hey what if
we see something interesting there this
is a an integral part of the work of
computational social science of course
but when you when you try to present
these in a more compelling way you say
hey I thought of everything in advance
and then
so if there are no more questions we can
thank the speaker and
[Applause]